Sal adrenal cocktails like this one are
supposed to help with something called
adrenal fatigue its symptoms include
trouble sleeping salt and sugar Cravings
body aches depression anxiety and brain
fog but the most common is feeling tired
influencers unsubstantiated claims
suggest that these small glands are
getting out of balance they swear that
regularly taking these cocktails or
taking adrenal supplements is the answer
to getting these glands back in top
shape but do these DIY cocktails or
over-the-counter supplements actually
work on social media people are saying
that the main culprit for adrenal
fatigue is chronic stress more
specifically the way it makes the
adrenal glands crank out a lot of
cortisol a stress hormone the theory is
that over time this overproduction
fatigues the adrenals and decreases
their ability to make cortisol and then
we end up feeling fatigued or even
unmotivated the hormone isn't just
related to stress it's also critical for
basic functions like regulating blood
pressure and sugar levels that's what
the combo of OJ coconut water sea salt
and cream of tartar is supposed to
combat coconut water and cream of tartar
are high in potassium an electrolyte
that's involved in maintaining healthy
blood pressure sea salt contains sodium
another important electrolyte that the
body uses to keep muscles and nerves
working properly and to stay hydrated
and OJ has vitamin C which is an
important antioxidant all this sounds
pretty good right but we do not have any
evidence to support that this specific
combination of ingredients supports the
adrenal gland specifically or that these
ingredients affect the amount of
hormones they produce Priya also said
that for people with kidney disease or
high blood pressure the high amounts of
potassium in coconut water and cream of
tartar could actually be harmful and the
sugar from juicing is also not great
especially if you're prone to or already
have diabetes given levels of Stress and
Anxiety AR Rising this trend makes sense
so when patients come to me asking about
a adrenal cocktails they're hoping to
improve their energy levels potentially
improve libido and just improve their
overall sense of well-being she and
other hormone specialists say that it's
not as simple as just looking at
cortisol levels they naturally go up and
down depending on a lot of factors like
time of day and whether you've eaten the
tiredness and other symptoms people
experience could be caused by a variety
of health issues adrenal fatigue is not
considered a medical disease but your
symptoms should be considered and be
heard now there is a similarly named
condition called adrenal insufficiency
with a list of symptoms that will sound
familiar patients report fatigue muscle
weakness joint pain loss of appetite
craving salty foods and depression but
this condition is pretty rare the most
common type affects somewhere between
50,000 and 92,000 people in the US by
comparison there are more than 6 million
people with Alzheimer's and roughly 37
million with
diabetes supplements are also a common
way that people try to boost their
adrenal health and this is this is where
things can backfire most cases of
adrenal insufficiency happen when
patients stop taking cortical steroids
which are anti-inflammatory drugs in
2018 researchers found that 12 popular
adrenal supplements contained hormones
including cortisol and glucocorticoids
AKA corticosteroids they did this study
after noticing that patients with
adrenal insufficiency symptoms had one
big thing in common taking supplements
none of the labels had these hormones
listed as ingredients you don't know
what's actually inside the supplement if
you don't have adrenal insufficiency
long-term exposure to corticosteroids
can actually harm your adrenals
manufacturers are only legally required
to include this disclaimer on their
labels in the last 2 years the FDA has
sent a handful of warning letters to
adrenal supplement vendors over the
claims their products are making the
burden of proof that a supplement might
be causing harm falls to the US
government the experts I talked to said
that before taking any supplement you
should talk to your doctor they also
worry that self-prescribing adrenal
cocktails might actually delay getting
at the root cause of what people are
feeling doctors also said that we
shouldn't discount basic but underrated
activities that boost our health you
need to walk you need to get your
movement in you need to exercise you
need to sleep stay hydrated manage and
reduce your stress eat a balanced diet
and all that might get you further
towards a healthier life than a mocktail
or a
[Music]
pill